[Music]
evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution I'm Steve Hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro-worker
pro-family pro community and of course
pro America with me live in Los Angeles
for the hour Tommy Loren Steve Moore and
Katrina Pierson Plus Jenna Ellis is here
then actually she's in DC there she is
and also tonight President Trump
praising Arnold Schwarzenegger you can
find out what that's about in my
exclusive conversation with the
Governator but first over at the jeff
bezos post they say democracy dies in
darkness but it's too late you may have
missed it but I'm sorry to tell you that
our democracy did in fact die this week
but thank God MSDN sees Rachel Maddow
was on hand to chronicle the sad demise
of our great Republic the Justice
Department has been thrown into crisis
and chaos institutions will not save you
institutions will not save you but what
do we do next what do we do what do we
do about it how dangerous and bad this
is the alarms are ringing sound the
alarm that way and all of the alarms
have sounded as the president rips these
systems out by the root this is
something to save our country that must
be stopped
alarm sounded we're awake seriously okay
it's actually that kind of hysterical
ranting that threatens our democracy
because it just hypes people up when we
should be trying to come together to
solve problems in fact if Rachel Maddow
truly believes in protecting our
democracy and I believe she's sincere
about that she should be praising what
happened this week here are the facts
this is the table the judiciary uses to
calculate sentences it is literally a
points-based system last November Roger
stone was convicted of seven felony
counts that together gave him 21 points
on that table you see there he's in
column one because it's a first offense
21 points means a sentencing guideline
of 37 to 46 months around three to four
years now prosecutors can add points for
different circumstances one of them is
if a defendant threatened a witness with
physical violence that adds 8 points
because Roger stone told a witness that
he should quote prepare to die the
prosecutors increased stones points
total to 29 which means a sentence of 87
to 108 months around nine years but this
was a ridiculously literal
interpretation of what was basically a
joke the witness who was allegedly
threatened told the court he didn't take
it seriously add to that the fact that
the prosecutors making the
recommendation had anti-trump political
backgrounds and the US Attorney 4dc
Timothy Shea not Attorney General Barr
overruled the prosecutors and proposed a
more lenient sentence this is a vital
fact left out of the whole establishment
freakout over this the decision to
reduce the sentencing recommendation was
made last week not by a G bar and before
anyone knew about it all tweeted about
it so then what happened well according
to DOJ sources cited by Kimberly
Strasser of The Wall Street Journal the
four prosecutors didn't like being
overruled so they threatened to resign
in the face of that threat US Attorney
Timothy Shea reversed his decision and
went with the original nine year
recommendation it was only at that point
that attorney general Barr intervened
not to make the decision himself but
simply to back the original judgment of
the US Attorney now in the light of
those facts consider what politicians
said last week his assault on the rule
of law by engaging a political
interference in the Senate
sentencing of his associate Roger stone
indicated that obstruction and
investigation into Trump Russia ties and
witness tampering AG bar has deeply
damaged the rule of law ridiculous she
could barely read the words out from
that bit of paper what actually happened
here was the exact opposite of what she
said you had a politically motivated
investigation mullah initiated by Trump
haters at the highest levels of our law
enforcement bureaucracy aimed at
overturning an election result they
disapproved of the investigation failed
to establish the central charge Trump
Russia collusion because it was
fabricated
to try and show something for their
years of work and millions of dollars
they prosecuted a handful of processed
crimes in Rogers stones case it wasn't
even a fair trial with a jury forewoman
who is politically biased against him he
was convicted and then the sentence
recommended by politically motivated
prosecutors was way out of whack if you
want to see abuse of power if you want
to see the undermining of the rule of
law all you have to do is look at the
last three years in which some of the
most powerful institutions in our
country the FBI the CIA the Justice
Department the Congress have been
corrupted to pursue a political vendetta
not by President Trump but against him
now finally we have an attorney general
who is standing up for the rule of law
and impartial justice free of political
interference and the president is
fighting back against the resistance
inside his administration the
establishment went nuts about that too
he fired VIN Minh and Salman he also
threw in VIN mends brother they said it
was just awkward to keep them that would
prove to be a lie that caps a week of
apparent impeachment revenge for
president Trump was for no one being
above the law if you're now as the
president is acting as if he is even the
president's former chief of staff John
Kelly joined in saying VIN Minh quote
did exactly what we teach them to do
from cradle to grave what a joke
how long do you think John Kelly would
have tolerated a soldier in his regiment
who was actively trying to get him out
Kelly himself plotted and schemed to
undermine president Trump's agenda
policies that were explicitly voted for
in an election he tried to stop him
building a wall he's a very definitely
changed his attitude towards the darker
issue and even the wall once we briefed
him once we briefed him sorry but who
elected John Kelly to countermand an
order from the voters what arrogance
this brings us to the big takeaway from
all of this the sheer scale and
shamelessness of the establishments
anti-democratic assault on Donald
Trump's populist revolution the
president gets a lot of grief for his
tweeting and okay fine
probably have done without some of it
this week but think about why he needs
that direct communication think what
he's up against as we've noted many
times he's not an ideologue he's a
pragmatic problem-solving businessman in
2016 he made a bunch of promises very
specific he got elected he thinks okay
now I need to get it done but oh no not
with these jokers once he's in the White
House he's surrounded by people trying
to stop him delivering his promises of
course internal disagreement is healthy
but in business there's a saying
disagree then commit with those around
this president too often it was disagree
then resist for Trump getting elected
was the easy part
the real battle was with the swamp once
he got there they blocked him they
investigated him they frustrated him
from Congress to the courts to the
federal bureaucracy to his own White
House staff the critics say why does he
give jobs to Jared and Ivanka because he
can trust them to work for his agenda
not against it like the swamp people and
by the way they're the ones actually
getting things done like us MCA along
with Robert light Heiser the pro worker
pro-family results.that Ivanka Trump is
helping to deliver Attorney General bar
to a principled and courageous leader
and long may he stay he is exactly what
we need at the Justice Department
in a trump second term the president
needs only people like this only people
committed to his agenda clear out the
bureaucratic resistance all of it
no more swamped Stooges like James
Madison HR McMaster no more arrogant
entitled Knowles who think they have the
right to block the policies 63 million
Americans voted for and put in their
place a failed elitist globalist
disaster that nobody supports except the
other swamp creatures they hang out with
at Washington dinner parties fire them
all drain the swamp close down
departments blow up the bureaucracy
decimate the civil service literally
look it up I mean literally decimate
more constitutionalist judges more power
to the states more power to communities
above all power to people
school choice lower taxes less
regulation it's called self-government
that's the next revolution we need and
that is the lesson of this week please
follow us acts
deep Hilton X and at next reven fnc